I got thrown out of a bar in New York
City now when I say I got thrown out of
a bar I don't mean somebody asked me to
leave we walk to the door together and I
said bye everybody I gotta go
six bouncers hurled me out of a
nightclub like I was a frisbee those big
old bouncers that go home every night
watch Roadhouse and beat off you know
I'm talking about that Patrick Swayze's
hitting another guy for wearing a hat I
walk into a bar with a hat on this guy
real piss he goes took off the Hat I
might wants to deal he goes I tell you
what the deal is [ __ ] in this area
where hatch we're trying to keep might
of a club I all really the only way we
could tail down south is if they have
their hair cut like you're
and he got all pissed but he walked away
and I took the hat off and like an hour
later I've been drinking and I forgot
you ever forget happened to me I put the
hat back on the guy comes over to me now
I'm between six one and six six
depending on which convenience store I'm
leaving I weigh 235 pounds this guy
comes over to me poking me and his
shoulder with two fingers says you're
out of here
wow thanks scooter and I was wrong they
hurled my ass and then they squared off
with me in the parking lot and I backed
down from the fight because I don't know
how many of them it would have taken to
whip my ass but I knew how many they
were going to use it's a handy little
piece of information to have right there
overkill well they called the police
because we broke a chair on the way out
the door and I refused to pay for it the
cops showed up and at that point I had
the right to remain silent but it didn't
have the ability
the cop says mr. white you are being
charged with drunk in public I was drunk
in a bar they threw me into public I
don't want to be drunk in public I want
to be drunk in a goddamn bar which is
perfectly legal arrest them well he
didn't arrest them instead they call in
for my arrest record there's some good
news
satellites are linking up in outer space
computer banks at NASA are kicking on
there's a Telegraph infinity this part
extra whopper shorthand beep now I told
you that story to tell you this story
when I was 17 years old I was arrested
for being drunk in public seemed to be a
pattern if you knew Morse code you would
already know that when one DWI which was
a bogus charge because it turns out they
were stopping every vehicle traveling
down that particular sidewalk and that's
profiling I believe in the drunken
public charge and Fritz the arresting
officer who I had literally known all my
life you know what I mean this guy live
four doors down from me in a town of
less than 400 people we've met he takes
me to jail when we get there he asked me
if I have any aliases and I was just
being a smartass and said yeah they call
me tater salad
17 years later in New York City I'm
handcuffed on a bench with blood coming
out of my nose this cop goes are you
wrong tater salad white you caught me
you caught the tater you can take down
those roadblocks now I call my son Tater
Tot and boot